dan yet Daniel is with us in Dallas hi
Daniel how are you are you doing better
than I deserve what's up so my wife and
I are somewhere in between two days two
weeks from Friday being out of being out
of date so - yay so we'll call back and
do our screams in so I'll be really
excited to call on that so my question
is we've been really going to so intense
we paid off about once we're done we'll
be it about six to seven thousand
dollars it about two and half years why
the goal and congratulations yeah it's
been really good and then I think my
question is we both can work in second
job so when is when does Dave Ramsey
give permission for us to rest and our
second job you're an adult and now
you're a successful adult you get to
decide things okay I don't need Dave
Ramsey's permission to do squat really
well for us I figured I ask one more
time
yeah I mean you're you guys have been
working 80 hours and 90 hours a week and
you something like that I mean she's
been working a little more she gets over
time I'm a city worker I get hopped on
so I don't get that benefit but we've
probably been working about 50 60 hours
a week each of us yeah it's a math thing
right when they when that when the dad
is gone and you're working baby step
three
how fast do you want to build your
emergency fund for sure you quit the
second jobs after baby step three a
hundred percent okay the only question
is how fast do you want to build baby
step three if you want to build it a
little bit slower because you quit the
second jobs ding ding - go ahead
probably four months to build up our
baby you've been going and you've been
going like a crazy people for two and a
half years and you got your debt paid
off so if you want to take an extra
month to build that oh well that's fine
or if you get close and she could pick
up some OT that last month and go after
it again for a little bit
I mean the good news though is ot it's
not like you have to quit the job you
just say I don't want to you're I do
want it yeah the second job is the thing
that's like you know we're ready to
start spending time with a family little
bit more face it me nervous you know we
want to take advantage of it yeah I mean
that's that could be your reward they're
gonna be part of your debt-free
celebration you know I quit but that
it's just it you're just you make that
adult decision you're making them it how
quick does it do if it makes a one-month
difference I'm with you I'd probably
quit I'm kind of right there so you know
that's the deal